- I feel like a boyfriend now.
This is the first time.
I'm like, this is what it's
like to be a boyfriend.
We're trying on boyfriend jeans.
- And by we, he means he's
trying on boyfriend jeans.
- I'm trying on them on.
- Boyfriend jeans are like jeans,
that are like a little looser on girls.
- He's actually worried that he's gonna
fit into them really well.
- I am!
- And somehow that's gonna emasculate him.
- I'm scared what if
they fit me and then I'm
wearing girl jeans that fit me as a man.
That's not, I'm nervous.
- I think it seems like a common
mistake that could happen.
Like at Nordstrom, I'm walking around,
boyfriend jeans.
I'm a boyfriend, I'ma try on these jeans.
- Got a big butt so you know,
- That's true.
- I don't think these jeans
are gonna get over that butt
but we'll see.
- Okay.
- You ready to do it?
Let's do it.
- They look a little weird
but I don't know why.
But they don't look that weird.
- I like them.
- You do?
- I like them actually.
They're kind of rugged looking, you know?
- They're very plain.
I would say there's nothing
like exciting about these.
- I love these like, I'm not gonna lie.
I might foot the bill for this
and rock these out.
- I'm gonna go rummage and play
some pick up football outside.
- I'm shocked.
- I'm feeling good right now, yeah.
- Boyfriends would not wear this color.
What is this?
- Loving the fit because it's loose
in the crotch area.
But it's tight right here so
it's like skinny jeans 2.0.
- I feel a lot more
active all of a sudden.
- Look at that, look at that knee action.
- Wow.
- How high it's getting.
If somebody come at me,
you could get some knee, you know?
- Okay do all girls jeans,
are they as useless as this?
Because these pockets do nothing.
- That's a normal women's pocket.
- Yeah okay well I don't know.
- They're a little short you know?
- I wear a lot of fancy socks
so that's actually a plus for me.
- Oh yeah.
- Look at this hole in the upper thigh.
- I like this, I think this looks cool.
- Who designed this?
Whose idea was that right there?
Hmm? Because right there
you can see my underwear.
- Your butt doesn't look good.
- My butt doesn't look good in these?
- No.
- Why?
- You know, I think --
- Oops, I dropped something.
- Oh no, oh no.
- To be honest, I don't
know what it is but
I don't think them on him.
- They're a little different.
They fall a little bit differently.
- Are your jeans tighter than this? No.
- Yeah my jeans are tighter than this.
- What do you mean? Its
like, oh, watch yourself!
Watch yourself, watch yourself!
Watch out.
- This is kind of dangerous.
- I think boyfriend jeans
might also be for boyfriends.
I'm just throwing it out there.
- I am not pleased with
this boyfriend jean thing.
- I see what they're going for and
- He likes this boyfriend
thing way more than I do.
- I like it, yeah.
- I want to wear dude pants
if you wear girl pants.
- Well these aren't girl pants
they're boyfriend jeans.
- Don't feel like my jeans.
These are not my boyfriend jeans.
- These get the boyfriend
seal of approval from me.
I think so.
- You know these are women's,
were bought in the women's department.
- Yeah but hey, you know?
If it looks good on me,
I can't help whatever it says.